this is cereth registered nurse Orion
comm and in this video I'm going to
demonstrate how to assess the upper and
lower extremities and if you would like
to watch a complete head-to-toe nursing
assessment you can access this card up
here in the corner or in the youtube
description below now before performing
this skill you'll want to perform hand
hygiene provide privacy to the patient
and tell them what you will be doing so
let's get started so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna inspect the extremities
and we're looking for any lesions any
redness swelling and this is a good time
if they have a central line an IV that
you look at that make sure it's not red
does IV need to be changed that's that
PICC line or central line need a
dressing change assess that then you can
palpate and what we're gonna do is we're
going to palpate our pulse our radial
artery so fill those bilaterally and
they are two plus and they're equal then
we're gonna check capillary refill and
to do that we're just gonna press down
on that nail bed and see how fast it
comes back in it's less than two seconds
then we're gonna check skin turgor but
just pinch in the skin and see how fast
it goes back and that was good then
we're just gonna look at the range of
the motion of the fingers and the hands
look at these joints in the hands you
see anything I'm normal
like for instance like her badeen or
both shards nodes which are found in
osteo arthritis and ask the patient are
you having any pain in your hands or
anything like that no then you can
palpate the brachial artery which is
found in the bends of the arm and just
fill those because that's another pull
site and those are two plus and just as
a side note if this was a patient that
was getting dialysis and they had an AV
fistula you would want to palpate that
and feel for the thrill make sure that
that is present up in that arm wherever
their fistula is at then you want to
test the muscle strength so what we're
gonna do is I'm gonna have you squeeze
my fingers as hard as you can okay okay
that's really good then I'm gonna have
you push up against my hands and I'm
push up against your arms okay push okay
very good okay and five plus normal
strength then we're just going to test
his put your hand underneath the elbow
and just fill as you move the arm do you
feel any grading crepitus of those
joints one times an arthritis you can
fill that and move that bilaterally
another thing you want to do with the
upper extremities is to check for a
drift and what you will do is you'll
have the patient hold out their arms and
close their eyes hold it up for about
ten seconds and you're looking for a
drift like this so go ahead do that and
close your eyes okay and we're assessing
to see if this hand will drift upward
and a lot of times if a patient has had
a stroke okay you can put them in has
had a stroke or something like that you
will see a drift now we're going to
assess the lower extremity so first of
all we're gonna do is we're going to
inspect we're gonna look at the color
from the legs to the toes making sure
it's nice and pink and here we see that
being has a little bit of a tan line and
we're looking at the hair growth as well
you want to make sure there's normal
hair hair growth because of PVD you will
see hairless shiny thin legs in here we
have excellent hair growth and also do
you see any abnormal swelling just right
off the bat before you've even touched
the patient and look at the legs and the
feet for any swelling redness swelling
do you have any pain or anything in your
legs anything like that and look in the
at the joints make sure there's no
redness on the joints cuz a lot of times
with gout it likes to start out in the
big toe so make sure that everything
looks good and then on your diabetic
patients make sure you look at the
bottoms of their feet because these
patients don't have the best feeling in
their feet so their shoes could be
wearing on them or they could have
stepped on something and not even know
it so inspect those feet make sure
there's no ulcers or anything that like
that that needs to be addressed also
look at the toenails so the toenails
look healthy or is there fungus are they
missing toenails they have a really bad
ingrown toenail so assess for that next
you want a pouch
your pulses will palpate the popliteal
pulses which are behind the knee
and those are about two plus they're
equal bilaterally I'm just filling his
legs they're nice and warm and I'm going
to push over his tibia firmly and I'm
seeing if there's any edema so push
there and if there is a d-mail a lot of
times whenever you push down it's like
this hard light type gel it'll just
separate and your finger will leave this
indention in here we don't have any now
we're going to palpate on the feet and
we're gonna feel on the pulses and I'm
gonna Don gloves perform hand hygiene
and Don gloves and we're gonna feel on
the pulses and this feet we're gonna
feel on the posterior tibial
tu+ really good and then we're gonna
feel the dorsalis pedis which is on top
of the foot 2 plus with that and if you
can't ever find these because sometimes
these are hard to find in patients you
can get a Doppler if you have one on
your floor next we want to check the
capillary refill on his toes just like
how we did with the fingers by pushing
down in less than two seconds check the
other one okay now I'm going to have him
push against my hands push against my
hands man okay good job now I'm gonna
have you raise your legs against
resistance good job now we're going to
check the Babinski reflex and you can
use your reflex hammer for this and use
the end of it or you can use your finger
if you don't have that and what we're
gonna do is we're going to take this up
through the ball of the foot and curve
it and we're looking for the toes to
curl in which would be a negative normal
response so let's check that okay okay
and that was normal then we're gonna
Dolf her gloves and perform hand hygiene
okay so that wraps up how to assess the
upper and lower extremities and don't
forget to check out the complete nurse
head-to-toe assessment video thank you
so much for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos